this week we had the awesome opportunity
to speak with a member of the israeli
defense force at an actual iron dome
site on the ground in israel he answered
my questions about the recent conflict
you can only get it here
on youtube but first this video is
sponsored by ring if you liked the video
please like and subscribe below enjoy
from the
actual site of an iron dome at batteries
lieutenant colonel jonathan conricos
he's international spokesperson
for the idf lieutenant colonel thanks so
much for joining the program really
appreciate the time
thank you ben thanks for having me so
let's talk about for a second
uh the efficacy of iron dome so i see
behind you it looks like you have a
battery for iron dome how does iron dome
work for people who don't even
understand
you know what the technology does think
of a magic sphere
protecting civilians you see the part
behind me
that's a part of interceptors each
interceptor
costs nearly 100 000 us dollars
[Music]
and one interceptor intercepts one
rocket
now hamas has fired more than four
thousand
rockets at israel and the interception
rate is
ninety nine zero percent and uh
unfortunately as i said we've had 12
civilians in israel killed
but other than that the iron dome has
been performing
outstandingly simply amazing it provides
that strategic
flexibility for israel we're lowering
the amount of casualties in israel i
wouldn't want to imagine
not in terms of israel and certainly not
in terms of gaza and other palestinians
what the situation would be like if we
didn't have the iron dome it's
absolutely strategic
it's the first of its kind in the world
a combat
proven system just 10 years old that is
able to intercept everything from a
small
rocket a mortar to a big 10 15 20 feet
rocket
so it's very versatile and for the first
time we've also intercepted a mixed wing
drone
an explosive kamikaze drone that hamas
tried to
dispatch at one of our cities we
intercepted it with the iron dome which
is the first time
worth mentioning this system is israeli
and us-made
there's israeli and american brain power
in this it's the
child of the cooperation between between
israel and the us
and i'm happy to say that today it's
used by israeli
and u.s armed forces and i think that's
amazing that u.s has this
technology using it as well i hope that
the u.s will never need to use it to
defend their civilians
or their troops but i can assure you
that it's an outstanding system
so the theory has been going that hamas
here was basically attempting
to overwhelm iron dome with the sure
number of rockets that were being fired
and that while iron dome was stopping 90
that means 10 percent uh are either
falling in unpopulated areas
or or getting through uh and that this
is more of a preparation
by hamas for the possibility of the
hezbollah from the north which has
something like 150 000 rockets ready uh
would attempt to overwhelm iron dome in
sure numbers how much of a threat is
that
so you're you're spot on the issue here
is quantity
so far in 12 days of fighting and 4
000 rockets fired the system has
performed
excellently and it has not been
overwhelmed it has delivered
it is the average interception rate is
on par
with its previous interception rate in
regular times
so the system is definitely scaling up
we've added battalions we've added
interceptors we've enhanced our logistic
capabilities of reloading these pods
behind me
because they fire at the very high rate
there are some
batteries down south in southern israel
which
have been uh replenishing their
ammunition
20 times a day 20 parts a day like this
in terms of the rockets that are fired
for instance in ashkelon
that city has sustained about 500
rockets per day
for 12 days straight think of those
figures it's it's unimaginable figures
imagine what it feels like to be a
civilian living under such kind of
threats
and i don't want to imagine how it will
without the iron dome
but yes the threat in terms of the north
is a very grave one
much bigger than what we're facing from
hamas in the south
hezbollah is a really a terror army
with more firepower than many european
militaries have today
and that's amazing when you think of it
11-time militia
that has a country holding a nation
state hostage for its purposes
has more firepower than a european than
many european countries
and that's a threat the problem is that
the world and the international
community doesn't understand
that if there are more casualties in
israel the idf will have to respond
much stronger against the areas that
they're from where we're being fired
upon
we won't have to have the ability to be
nice and uh
and and only do precision strikes no if
there will be sustained rocket fire at
our civilians
overwhelming our defensive systems the
only answer will be
uh significant use of firepower against
the sources of fire
and that would be a totally different
situation for lebanon so we sure hope
that
is watching learning paying attention to
to what's happening and paying attention
to the combat capabilities of the air
force
and draws his own relevant conclusions
from this we'll get back to lieutenant
colonel conreacus in just
one second first let me tell you about
keeping my family safe and secure so
i've got a lot of little kids running
around my property
i got to keep my eye on them but they're
faster than i am i rely
on my ring devices and you should too a
lot is happening at your front door
these days if somebody stops by or
something is going on outdoors around my
house ring
lets me know it's peace of mind anytime
knowing my home is protected to get ring
alarm for yourself head on over to
ring.com
ben it's the perfect way to start your
ring experience there are a thousand
reasons why protecting your home matters
to you
protect your whole home with ring alarm
a powerful affordable whole home
security system
you can easily install yourself ring has
security products for every corner of
your home inside and out
best of all you can see it all in one
simple app you can keep an eye on your
home no matter where you are right from
your phone
if somebody stops by or something is
going on ring will let you know it's
peace of mind anytime knowing
your home is protected when my family
moved from california to florida first
thing my wife said is when we move in we
got to get ring on the house
we did start protecting your home the
same way i did with ring alarm
go to ring.com ben get your ring alarm
security kit today can build the system
right for your home
have it up and running in minutes that's
ring.com once more ring.com slash ben
we're speaking lieutenant colonel
jonathan kenrick it's international
spokesperson for the idf
so final question for you uh lieutenant
colonel the
the media has refused to cover in detail
the sorts of human rights violations
that hamas has been carrying out aside
from simply firing rockets into civilian
areas there was an attack
in the last couple of days on on an aid
thoroughfare there was an aid
thoroughfare that was opened by israel
israel is attempting to ship
in human aid to gaza and hamas attacked
the thoroughfare hamas has been engaged
in regular human rights violations
throughout this campaign including
hiding obviously military resources in
places like the the same building that
was occupied by the associated press
maybe you can talk a little bit about
what we know about hamas's human rights
violations
yeah you know what i'd like to say about
that is that it's i'm simply astounded
by the level the lack of effort
of international media in documenting
and honestly reporting
what hamas is doing on ground and
underground in gaza
they're simply giving them a pass and
you won't see
any pictures from any of the agencies
any of the big
networks and papers of what hamas is
doing inside
today to date i haven't seen one single
image
of a rocket being fired from a house or
from close to a house in gaza
and that happens dozens of times a day
sometimes even more than that and not
even one single picture
we've sent those pictures out videos
live videos of rocket launches that are
nested
just inside a house a house courtyard
close to schools
mosques hospitals everything and there's
zero
documentation of that there's zero
reporting of that there's
zero reporting of any armed personnel
you haven't seen a single hamas
operative in uniform
in any of the networks and i think it's
just an atrocity there's so much
scrutiny and criticism of israel
that's fine scrutiny is good it makes
sure that everything is okay
but how about looking at what the
terrorist organization on the other side
does against israel and why isn't that
being documented
and where's the global outcry as to the
purpose the
the violations done by them well it
continues to be an astonishing fact that
israel does its best to prevent civilian
casualties while defending its citizens
and yet the world
uh all too often seems to be willing to
slip into a moral equivalence that's
utterly unjustifiable on the ground by
the facts lieutenant colonel
henriquez really appreciate the time and
appreciate what you're doing thank you
very much ben
have a good day i hope you enjoyed that
interview with lieutenant colonel
konricus if you want more content like
this
please like and subscribe below